The Joe Rogan Experience I think I've
been Florida man a few times
add that to my belt how did you get
involved in Honey pythons first of all
can you bring that python head up yeah
you see that python head
I did see so so this really didn't look
this is actually the one that bit me
that I almost bled out in the middle of
the Everglades caught by myself in the
middle of the Everglades and that bit
you yeah yeah this snake 17 foot seven
inches
135 pounds and that's no eggs inside of
it no meal inside of it that Solid Snake
muscle and at the time that's about what
I weighed so it was a fair Everglades
Battle Royale oh my God can I see it
yeah absolutely now tell me the scenario
what happened
so um I was I found this thing yeah and
look at all those teeth look at that
it's insane yeah and and that head
actually has shrunk substantially from
the freeze drying process all Critters
freeze-dried that for me and uh you know
it takes all the moisture out of it
really really shrinks down
um so I was out hunting the Everglades
um I was actually out in my 14-foot John
Boat by myself and I was checking uh
spoil Islands out there these islands
were dug maybe a hundred years ago or
more
um when they dug the canal they were
made 100 years ago when they were
digging the canal
and they've been up there you know
gaining vegetation getting real nasty
and a lot of these Critters come up on
them to breed to feed and to nest and I
was out there looking for you know a
python like I normally do and I came
across her I knew immediately when I saw
her that she was very large possibly the
largest python I've captured
and I could only see the um the back
half of her maybe like the back third
over
but I could tell she was a monster
my heart is pounding uh I'd be lying to
you if I said it wasn't
but you know my main fear in a situation
like that is not that this snake's gonna
kill me I'm confident in how to handle
these animals uh confident in in my
ability but I'm worried this thing's
going to get the best of me overpower me
and possibly I lose it
um it gets away into the swamp to eat
more of our native Wildlife coming
across an animal like this even with the
situation we're in in the Everglades is
still a once in a lifetime you know
opportunity it really is I've caught a
number of them but I spend a lot of time
out there
so I'm getting ready to
capture this this snake building myself
up to it uh the safest way to go about
it is to find the head grab the head
with both my hands and keep her from
coiling on me wrapping around me
uh I can't find her head her head's
buried in vegetation buried in in the
maiden cane I just can't see it and
she's working her way slowly off the
island
so I know I gotta quickly do something
I'm afraid if I if I get closer to her
head I'm on a spooker and she's going to
try to start moving away
I grab onto her tail and this is kind of
a bad situation to be in especially with
all the thick vegetation these snakes
can easily overpower you and will
actually drag you out in the swamp
there's just no stop in it it
intertwines in all the weeds and just
drags you
so I know grabbing this thing my goal is
to piss it off and get it to start
striking at me where I can see that head
and grab a hold of that head otherwise
this thing's this thing's gone
so I get a hold of it and it starts
dragging me it's pulling me off the
island so is it wrapped around you are
you no no no no it's it's stretched out
and you're hanging on I'm hanging on it
yeah it's it's the this thing's eating
alligators eating deer it's the biggest
thing out here it's not worried about
nothing it's not scared of me you know
what I mean it's it's kind of seeing
what I'm doing
so I got a hold of it and it's starting
to are you wearing gloves no how are you
able to really grab it
if I had gloves on I wouldn't be able to
grab it I need my bare hands to be able
to work and and feel everything have the
grip
um gloves gloves will just get in the
way even something with like a texture
to it I don't want any of that okay I
don't want any of that they just get in
the way
um so I got the snake dragging me out
into the swamp uh you know losing this
battle
I'm able to dig my heels down into
limestone that I'm standing on the
Limestone Island and I'm able to to stop
her I'm not gaining honor but I got her
stopped and we're kind of in this
Everglades tug of war right now
and she starts to get pissed off she
starts hissing she starts turning around
on me and this this is what I want but
I gotta not get bit you know what I mean
um [__] a snake this size to my
advantage they're they're slower than a
smaller snake they have a lot of body
mass they're going to tire out quickly
and uh her strikes aren't going to be
lightning fast so she's striking at me
I'm dodging her strikes oh my God
everything's going good everything Floyd
Mayweather out there
and yeah doing a little ducking weave
everything's going good
um normally when a strike when a snake
strikes it's going to strike out recoil
back get ready
strike again recoil back it's how they
strike that's how they get that power
they kind of like recoil their body
so it's it's struck I dodged it it
recoils back like a third of the way and
hits me with this little sneak attack
strike that I wasn't expecting this
snake is
anywhere from 10 to 20 years or more old
so it's been around the block it's a
smart snake and um you know snakes don't
normally do that I think she she kind of
knew what she was doing
she struck she got me on my arm got an
artery got some veins coming off my
artery
and that that doesn't do it justice at
all um their their teeth are all their
punctures so uh you know they're like
needles so they punctured down deep you
can see you can see that top one gets
right into my main vein and the real bad
one was on the top of my arm that you
can't see
where it's on this I think it's an
artery I'm here wrong coming coming on
the top of my arm
and I got very lucky normally when they
bite they they latch on
and she would have latched on she would
have wrapped around me and you know I
would have been in a very very bad
situation being out there by myself
thank the good Lord I I had him on my
side that day she struck she bit I was
able to grab her head and I don't know
if it's how I pushed it forward and
pulled her off or what because all their
teeth are recurved like like fish hooks
almost kind of
got her right off of me grabbed her head
pushed her off of me she didn't latch on
she was trying to bite again maybe maybe
that she didn't think she had a good
bite and she was trying to re-grip but I
got lucky now I have her head I'm bit
I'm spraying blood
all over the Everglades but I I have her
head
so now now my main thing is controlling
her without exerting myself too much
because every time I'm doing anything I
mean it's it's I've never seen blood
come out of my body like this you know
really
um my heart's pounding adrenaline's
going and uh
my main thing is just to stay calm I
don't think I'm necessarily gonna bleed
to death I mean the amount of blood I'm
seeing it crossed my mind but but I
really don't think I'm gonna bleed to
death I'm worried about blacking out
from blood loss the heat exerting myself
what's this snake gonna do if I black
out
it's gonna wrap around me it's gonna
kill me 100 right
um you know I don't think it'd
necessarily be able to swallow me and
eat me maybe uh but it could definitely
kill me
so I'm really trying to control my heart
where heart rate trying not to exert
myself
um the snakes biting at me you know
going nuts uh you can see the video on
my YouTube of where I'm just covered in
blood and
um I have a snake bag with me to put
whatever snake I was planning on
catching in the bag this snake is way
too big for that bag so I actually am
able to use that bag to tie off my arm
and kind of do a little red nose you're
holding it down yeah why I got the the
head in one hand and I'm tourniquet in
my arm I think it was like this
tourniating my arm
with with the other and got my arm sent
shut you know kind of got the bleeding
under control and I was able to kind of
collect myself this snake is pretty much
worn out at this point she's
cold-blooded so they gas out after about
a 10 minute fight she's like a limp
noodle
so I'm kind of just laying on her
catching my breath
now I got to get her back to my boat
where I can put a bullet in her head
because I don't just walk out around out
there with a gun all these snakes I
catch alive put them in a bag and it's
just easier to not have a gun on me
Jesus and um why is it would it be so
hard to have a gun right there well I'm
I'm literally crawling through cane and
Sawgrass and it gets snagged you can
lose a gun very easily and it's just
it's in the way and 99.9 percent of the
time I'm not going to need one
especially me I'm the kind of guy where
if I come across a 30-foot snake you
know which pythons don't get that big
let's say I come across a 30-foot snake
some crazy I ain't shooting it I'm I
want to catch it you know that's dude
that's what I'm all about oh my God this
is this is you after this thing bit you
yeah this is right where I'm getting
ready to try to tourniquet my arm holy
[__] man and you're filming this yeah I
I got my shoulder cam on and then I put
a GoPro on the ground this is wild
and you know normally I I don't always
get great I mean I get pretty good
footage with myself on my shoulder cam
but like I I was set up this day and I
knew I had my GoPro running when this
thing bit me are you cinching up at the
top of your army above the wound above
the wound above the wound yeah above the
wound
and uh you know to be honest with you
the the first thought that went through
my mind when that thing bit me and I
have all these cameras going and I see
all this blood is this video is
definitely going viral just don't die it
would really go viral if you died yeah
I'm sure it would have yeah found GoPro
footage so now you have to carry this
thing out while you're holding onto its
head yeah well she really is like a limp
noodle while it's still alive
she really is like a wimp noodle yeah
she's gassed out she is done that's
insane she is done
wow man that's that's a man [__] right
there son
not a lot of human beings are capable of
doing that and just keeping it together
it's creeping me out just watching you
hold on to that thing as you're walking
through the the woods with it what I
think it is more than anything and you
know I hate to kind of take away from
myself but it's it's what we're taught
as kids you know we're taught to be
fearful of snakes that they're this evil
dangerous thing and I can't tell you I I
think that's why I've been so successful
on social media is these people they
just freak out watching these snakes you
know they can't believe it and it's
they're not really that crazy they're
really not I think you're just used to
them I think they're really [__]
crazy
that's the reason why they're only in
one state like this look at the size of
that thing man that thing's enormous and
they eat alligators oh yeah I think bro
I think they would eat you I've rescued
three alligators from pythons wow that's
actually how I started my social media
is I um made the news went kind of viral
for rescuing an alligator from a python
I had a guy out on a guided hunt with me
he uh recorded it videotaped it and it
you know made the news and uh a local
clothing brand flow grown in Florida
made my Instagram made my social media
and was like dude you gotta start using
it you know we'll send you clothes and
that's really how it all got started
that's crazy
that's how it got started that's amazing
look at these things and I actually this
was the smallest of the three I've
rescued
um it was the third one that we finally
got on video because I never I never
used to really record anything
imagine how [__] confused alligators
must be like I thought we were at the
top I we were at the top forever yeah oh
yeah what happened yeah what the [__] is
going on 2023 times are changing